William dum rodeado de sus seres
queridos
retratos de su hermano bombero fallecido
en la explosión del puerto de beirut
pueden verse en todos los rincones de su
casa familiar
el 13 de enero no fue detenido por
amenazar con explotar el tribunal
nacional un grito que salió desde el
corazón Ya que la investigación Lleva
más de un año suspendida debido a
presiones políticas
me llevaron a una celda sobre las tres
de la madrugada Fue entonces cuando mi
abogado me dijo que se había producido
una violenta pelea en biblos y que mi
tío había sido golpeado en la cabeza
estaba preocupado porque cuando el
ejército y las fuerzas de seguridad
deciden intervenir golpean a todo el
mundo
cerca de la casa familiar una iglesia de
memoria de Joe nunes todos los días
William viene a meditar y rezar por su
hermano
nos están intimidando para que dejemos
de pedir justicia es necesario el apoyo
internacional porque los políticos a los
que va a dirigir a la investigación
harán todo lo posible para impedir que
continúe
esta mañana William participa en un
plantón en el centro de beirut
organizado por las familias de las
víctimas los manifestantes señalan la
cultura de la impunidad en Líbano
ante la creciente influencia de los
políticos en el poder judicial amnistía
internacional pide que se apruebe el
proyecto de ley sobre la independencia
del poder judicial
uno de los principales problemas del
poder judicial en Líbano es el sistema
de nombramiento de los jueces en algunos
tribunales los jueces son nombrados
directamente por el gobierno o por el
órgano ejecutivo
el exministro de Justicia Ibrahim nayar
denuncia la falta de justicia y las
maniobras de las autoridades para
retrasar la investigación
tienen a su gente en el poder judicial
algunas personas están comprometidas por
el poder político
y es hora de que todo esto termine estoy
de acuerdo en que algunos jueces no
escuchan a su conciencia como jueces
de magistral por el momento la clase
dirigente se niega a abrir una
investigación internacional sobre la
explosión del puerto el 4 de agosto de
2020 murieron más de 200 personas 6.500
heridas y toda una parte de la capital
quedó destruida